the boys want to celebrate uh this great
milestone of American Idiot being 20 so
now they're going to play live in our
studio letter bomb off American Idiot
which is another great song anything you
want to say about letter bomb and why
you chose this today this one and it's
kind of a dedication
to the uh the anniversary so so we will
be playing it's a deeper cut so we will
be playing it live so I I love when you
play the deeper Cuts CU we don't hear
these all the time and um it's a great
song go ahead all right
[Music]
oh where Apple
the B's
gone the under Bell at up 10
night the dummy F the C set the r in
unemployment checks the funk is all
along for the
ride the where
andle R is
gone that's
SM
watch in love is how in dead on your
they can the [__] mat like this
feels the town B your time is such ass
don't even know that you exist so to to
die you better run for your [__] life
it's not other to you're Underground
it's to
late yes
bur yes
I'm this I'll before too
late where will all the mon go and the
vi
against and when won we all go and it's
too
[Music]
late
all the Jesus has to me up the a Jimmy
is a fing up your father's ra and your
mother's love maybe the in
America it's not over till you're
underr it's hard of before
to C is
bur let my
bur this for to
oh she said I can't take this place oh
leave it
behind see I can't take this shout I'm
leaving you
[Music]
lion
wow Robin's pan he's just landed on
Trey's head I can't believe dancing
around in my room that is so beautiful
boys you know isn't it funny like you
know you call that a deep track or
whatever but that could have like aren't
you surprised by what becomes a hit and
what becomes like a sort of what they
call secondary track you never know
right you know it never got released as
quote unquote a single but I think for
us what it's what's important is making
albums and so this is a song that was
like a part a big part of the album so
yeah you have bullevard broken dreams
you have American Idiot and wake me up
with September Ends but I think that
songs like that become kind of the most
important part because it really tells
the story of what gets deeper inside the
record and so when people hear it they
are they're like oh my God like I'm
you're just having if you're a music
lover you you you have a big
understanding of a better understanding
of what's going on inside the album It's
like a book you
know